well tonight clark county students are
celebrating because today was the last
day of school
victoria saha spoke to some families in
north las vegas
who are feeling a sight of relief after
a year of some big changes
we all know that feeling of walking out
of school on the last day
i'm happy that it's over rough year
i'm glad because i'm happy for the
summer i'm kind of shocked to be honest
that i made it
this far it wasn't just a normal school
year for goings elementary principal
brandi march
there were a lot of changes and she
needed to make sure staff
and students could adapt here has
definitely been the most challenging in
my educational life
for sure so many
unexpected challenges going from online
learning to hybrid
to allowing in-person learning again
just last month
teacher rich ireland had to be flexible
i feel like we've persevered
through it all i feel like we've had
four different starts of the school year
this is like our fourth closing to the
school year and parents had to make
adjustments as well
it was tough on us it was hard us having
to learn how to be computer savvy
again because as parents we forget like
i couldn't really
like focus because we were at home
but the message on this last day of
school is for students to relax
enjoy the summer and return in august to
hopefully
normalcy victoria saha 8 news now